so first things first be prepared to
have your head kind of twisted a little
bit because of the induction proofs
inequalities are generally regarded as
one of the hardest it's part of why
there are so few inequality proofs
actually in the HSC we've been doing the
agency in its current form for like 30
years you guys like the last ones to go
through in this syllabus and even in
that time just have a look at the bottom
of the page that's how many of this kind
of question that I could find they're
not common what are the kinds of
induction proofs do you already know
what if you looked at over the past few
days divisibility prove that some
whatever expression is a multiple of
three or is divisible by five or
whatever divisibility what else series
series and sequences right so I prove
that this sum of things sorry this
series of things will add up to this
thing for N equals etc etc etc right do
you know any other kinds of induction
proofs there are some fun there are some
fun geometry proofs which are again
uncommon for example you can prove by
induction that the angle sum of a
polygon with n sides and an M gone has
an angle sum of that which you already
knew but you can prove that by induction
that's kind of nice neat sort of thing
to do it's the same idea i can build up
from like a small shape a triangle and
then i can go to the next one and the
next one the next one you keep on
building up there's many different kinds
the inequalities kind of require the
most extra thought because you're
already familiar with series of
sequences right we did a whole topic on
that you know what it means for
something to be divisible but you've
never really had to prove things with
inequalities and that's why I've got
this big preamble okay so here's my
first point make sure you have a sheet
of paper on the way in it will pass the
chance to it will pass the chair it's
got a piece of paper in it thank you
you're going to do lots of things to
inequalities then are just like what
you've done for years with equations
right it's like I've got a thing and
then I manipulate both sides and then I
get an answer at the bottom except in a
really big way and I'm gonna outline a
few of them actually inequalities are
the opposite of equations and you kind
of can tell from the name
that's it's like we're saying it not
equal so you can't do everything to an
inequality that you do with an equation
okay
first example we've got if a equals B
right let's just take any two numbers
then for instance I could multiply both
sides of this by negative 1 right and
this is you can put this in that top
left-hand blank cell there right this
tells you that negative a equals
negative B regardless of what a and B
are equal to there could be numbers
there could be functions they could
anything you like
okay you multiply both sides by negative
1 no problem but this is not always the
case when you think about inequalities
right over on the right hand side now
right let's think of a really
straightforward inequality like say I'm
pretty sure negative 2 sorry yeah I'm
pretty sure negative 2 is less than 1
you agree with that you're happy that
negative 2 it's over there on the number
line and 1 is over here but watch what
happens when we multiply both sides by
negative 1 just like we did over here
what am I going to get here 2 and then
over here I'm going to get negative 1
and that's not less than negative 1
right so this is like the classic
example when you multiply by negative 1
what should I actually do to the
inequality what happens to it let's get
a switch direction right now this is
switching of direction so I should
actually write 2 is greater than
negative 1 this switching of direction
is the thing you have to watch out for
because of course equations don't have a
direction you write a equals B you can
write B equals a it's the same thing on
both sides it's not the case when you
say for example this is my first one
when you multiply my negatives watch out
okay
all right secondly so here's on your
second row which one did I have second
if you've got a equals B then just like
multiplying both sides by negative 1 you
could also take the reciprocals of both
sides yeah you're happy with that if you
do that these two things were equal then
when you divide one of them through by
one and the same you'll get the same
thing right hmm what should we say here
how about on the right-hand side 3 is
less than 4 right
last I checked 3 is less than 4 but
seriously we need to call you have to
question yourself when I take the
reciprocals of both sides watch what
happens I'm going to get
one fat and one quarter that is not less
than right again you're actually going
to have to switch the direction so you
can't just simply do the same thing to
both sides have one last example oh yeah
that's right this one becomes very
important right lastly I think that's
the right number of rows you have three
rows right here we go here's the last
one you can multiply both sides by
negative one or equation you can take
the reciprocal of both sides you can
also square both sides you do have to be
cautious because if for example you had
something like x equals five you square
both sides x squared equals 25 and you
introduce an extra solution but it's
still true it's still true if x equals
five then you square it you still get 25
that's true but let's think of an
example can you think of an example I
gave you two here where when you tried
to do the operation it broke down can I
give you 30 seconds just write your own
something you know to be true something
you know to be true and then can you
square both sides and come up with
something where it doesn't land let me
give you a brief moment to have a think
about it see if you can think of an
example just square both sides and see
what happens is it consistent is it not
think about that for a second
has anyone come up with something a pair
of numbers get an inequality you square
both sides and it breaks down today
you're nodding what if you got or you're
not into yourself for a different reason
what you yeah okay negative five you're
saying is lesson G that we agree with
that yes that's true and then you square
both sides what happened and you're like
wait a second
that is not less than right and it's
probably helpful for us to know that's
that's negative five squared and that's
two squared so you did do what you were
supposed to do but again because of its
really the signs that are messing with
us with us and also the magnitude of
things right so here like I keep on
saying right you say oh when I square
both sides depending on the sign of both
sides you may have to change the
direction of the inequality like so so
do you see what I mean right these
things are not the same as equations
they're quite different objects now
there's one other way which I've got
underneath here which is really
important oh yeah that's right which is
to say that because you have the two
sides not being equal that's what an
inequality means they are not the same
they're kind of more and I was
struggling for a word for this so if you
after I explain this you can come with a
better word for this please tell me but
I call them kind of flexible right so
you can see there I've written 100 is
greater than 99 right which we're all
happy to say is true okay now if this
was in equation land right if you do
something to one side you must
absolutely do it to the other otherwise
it breaks down it's not an equation
anymore okay but that's not true for
inequalities watch I'm just going to
subtract one from the right-hand side
just because I feel like it 98 but I
don't have to subtract one from the
right-hand side from the left-hand side
and it's still true do you agree it's
like hey this thing is bigger than this
you can make this smaller if you like
you can make it smaller and smaller and
smaller and it's all still true this is
really weird people look at this in the
working like you'll go and look up
solutions for this and you think how did
they just change things on the
right-hand side think about it
you've got is a big object over here on
the left these things can keep getting
smaller you can make them as small as
you like have a look at the right hand
side I've got a different example for
you right you can see I've got seven and
eight because of a seven on the left
hand side my inequality is going not
greater than but lesser then right hmm
can I keep on getting things smaller on
the right hand side can I say 7 is less
than 7
no I can't can I but I could go in the
opposite direction right I could for
example instead of subtracting one just
because I felt like it I could maybe add
one instead that's still true isn't it
right I could keep on adding I could
make this as big as I want these things
because of the direction of the
inequality they can keep getting bigger
so this is a little strange and unusual
right we're not in equation land anymore
even though we're going to do as you'll
see a lot of things just like we would
with equations in these particular ways
it's particularly because of these
different qualities of inequalities I
didn't mean to say like that but because
inequalities are different in these ways
the proofs we're going to do are gonna
feel very different ok there's a
mounting questions on either of these 2
points okay let's get down to brass
tacks this is all general in terms of in
terms of inequalities now let's speak
specifically about induction there are
basically two ways to do this I like to
call them method 1 and Method 2 because
I'm very original in the way that I name
things ok and these are the things that
you sort of seen before but I'm gonna
try and state them in an explicit way
because otherwise you're like where do I
even begin okay so when we think about
induction there are three main steps
right can you tell me what the three
main steps are what's the first thing
you always do we're going to test right
what exactly are we going to test we're
going to test the first value for the
statement that you've been given right
and often the first value is N equals 1
but doesn't have to be in fact have a
look at the bottom of the page you can
see for most of those questions any
questions you've encountered already the
it doesn't have to be an equals one so
you test your base case that's the first
thing
after that you yeah you make an
assumption right you're like I haven't
written any of it on the board in those
statements there everything's to do with
ends that's meant to be a generalized
number let's pick a number let's just
call it K you make the assumption and
then your last step is after you've
tested after if you've assumed you okay
we we're gonna test out right but we
actually don't know like in some ways
you can't find it because K is like who
knows what K is right this is where the
real work begins you have to prove that
everything is actually gonna work for K
plus 1 if it works for K so this is
always the in acronym the acronym that's
in my head right I'm just going to like
a like a list of dominoes right tap it
and then it all goes that's the way
induction works
okay now method 1 and Method 2 very
overall they kind of look at these two
steps you're going to start from one
point or another okay
so method one is begin from the
assumption right you know for most of
the proofs that you've done so far you
kind of look at this k plus one thing
and then you like twist and turn it so
you can find the assumption in there and
then you you know you do a substitution
you say by assumption okay this one your
first line is just the assumption and
then you start working with it okay
that's method 1 method 2 is instead when
you've got the the k plus 1 step right
you state the k plus 1 case as
everything with k's your function of k
every single thing you see with k's in
it in the k plus 1 case you put it on
one side of the inequality right you
stated as this is bigger than this or
less then depending on which way you've
got your questions there too you say is
that and then consider that left-hand
side